هذا وتظاهر اليوم في تل ابيب وحيفا الاف
الاسرائيليين للمطالبه باقاله رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو وحكومته واجراء
انتخابات مبكره وجاءت الدعوه للتظاهر هذه
الليله تحت عنوان ان الاسرائيليين س
يستحقون قياده افضل لا سما لاخفائها في
منع هجوم السابع من اكتوبر والتهجم من قبل
وزراء في الحكومه على رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي هيرسي هاليفي خلال جلسه المجلس
الوزري المصغر يوم الخميس الماضي وقد نظم
هذه المظاهرات الذي التي خرجت في مدن
اسرائيليه اخرى نشطاء وممثلون عن
الاحتجاجات السابقه قبل اندلاع الحرب على
غزه والتي طالبت بوقف التشريعات القضائيه
الى جانب عائلات جنود قتلوا خلال الحرب
وسكان من مستوطنات غلاف
غزه وفي القدس اظهرت صور قمع الشرطه
الاسرائيليه متظاهرين طالبوا بوقف الحرب
على غزه والتوصل الى صفقه فوريه وحل
[موسيقى]
سياسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تو
معنا من تلبيب مراسل الجزيره محمد خيري
محمد كيف يتم في داخل اسرائيل متابعه كل
هذا الانقسام العسكري السياسي وحتى على
مستوى
الشارع بالفعل دعنا نبدا من الشارع
الاسرائيلي اليوم يعني هو هو السبت الثاني
الذي يشهد مظاهره بمشاركه عشرات الاف
الاسرائيليين مظاهرات بهذا الحجم منذ
السابع من اكتوبر هذه المظاهرات امتدت من
مدينه تل ابيب وكذلك الى مدينه حيفا والى
مدينه قيساريا حيث منزل رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ونادت باقاله
حكومه نتنياهو واجراء انتخابات اسرائيليه
مبكره حتى خلال استمرار الحرب المتظاهرون
يقولون ان نتنياهو هو سبب كل الخلافات في
اسرائيل وهو سبب الفشل الذي حصل يوم
السابع من اكتوبر وان تبديل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يعني امر ليس مستغربا وهناك
امثله عده في العالم على تبديل رؤساء
ورؤساء وزراء حتى اثناء الحرب الى جانب
هذه المظاهرات كانت هناك ايضا مظاهره ضخمه
في مدينه تل ابيب لاهالي الاسرى
الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه والذين يعني
قالوا اليوم علانيه انه لا يمكن ان ياتي
اليوم المئه لوجود الاسرى الاسرائيليين في
غزه دون التوصل الى حل من اجل اطلاق
سراحهم هذا يعني انهم اعطوا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مهله لمده اسبوع حتى الافراج
عن هؤلاء الاسرى وكذلك هددوا اليوم بتصعيد
الحراك في الشارع وكذلك تصعيد حركه
الاحتجاجات لتشمل عده مدن اسرائيليه
وهددوا بانهم يعني سوف يصعدون هذهه
الاحتجاجات مهما كان الثمن يعني خلال
المرحله المقبله وقالوا انهم لا يتلقون اي
اشعارات او معلومات من قبل الحكوم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والجهات المعنيه حول وضع
الاسرى في مدينه القدس يعني ايضا كانت
هناك مظاهره كبيره ايضا هذه المظاهره نادت
بوقف فوري للحرب على قطاع غزه هذا مشهد
نادر بدا في الحدوث مؤخرا خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره مظاهرات تنادي بوقف الحرب والتوصل
الى حل سياسي مع الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه
هذه المظاهره قمعت من قبل عناصر الشرطه
الاسرائيليه وكذلك اعتقل اعتقل ثلاثه من
المتظاهرين الذين شاركوا فيها واحالتهم
الشرطه الى التحقيق يعني واضح جدا ان حاله
الخلافات بدات تمتد من
اعلى الرؤوس الحكم في اسرائيل الى الشارع
الاسرائيلي الذي بدا يشارك في عمليه الضغط
على الحكومه والمستوى السياسي على وجه
الخصوص وخاصه في ظل الانباء التي تتسرب
الى المجتمع الاسرائيلي حول خلافات كبيره
جدا لدى الوزراء من جهه والجيش من جهه
اخرى وهي الخلافات التي كشف عنها خلال
اجتماع المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون
الامنيه والسياسيه والتي كان سببها هو
تشكيل رئيس هيئه الاركان الاسرائيلي فريقا
للتحقيق في فشل السابع من اكتوبر وهو ما
اثار حفيظه وزراء اسرائيليين نتنياهو الذي
يعني بالمناسبه دعى اليوم الى وضع
الخلافات جانبا وكذلك الى وقال ان الحرب
لا يمكن ان تتوقف قبل تحقيق كافه اهدافها
وهي يعني تفكيك حركه حماس وكذلك اعاده
الاصر وضمان ان لا يكون في غزه ما بعد
الحرب اي جهه تهدد اسرائيل نتنياهو هو
ايضا متهم باثاره هذه الخلافات هناك من
اشار الى ان الى ان عفوا ال الخلافات التي
دبت خلال اجتماع المجلس الوزاري كان يقف
من خلفها نتنياهو اخيرا دعني اقول ان هذه
الخلافات مستمره حتى خلال يعني بعد قبل
يومين من زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الى اسرائيل والذي يريد فعليا ان يسمع
ماذا اعدت اسرائيل لليوم التالي وهو امر
لم تبحث هو اسرائيل بشكل صحيح حتى الان
كما يشير البعض